this video is sponsored by hong kong
impact third
gamers gamers gacha gamers you know me i
love my 2d girls and hong kong pack 3rd
has the cream of the crop a free-to-play
3d action role-playing mobile game
developed and published by mihoyo the
same makers of gentian impact which
speaking of which they're having a
collaboration event
right now official will be joining as a
new valkyrie with her companion aussie
along with ka-ching
where you can free more powerful forces
for kuching to fight against the enemy
which includes the more powerful the
wolf of the north in this world
and most amazingly both of these
characters are completely
free sorry what does this word mean i've
never heard this word before as a gacha
gamer new players to join the game now
could win over 103 supply cards by
completing missions
and can even enter a sweepstake to win a
big mystery prize
and also from july 12th to august 12th
hong kong fact third will be
collaborating with bubble tea brand kung
fu tea
in the us and canada so you can join the
event for a chance to win limited merch
and an iphone 12.
so what are you waiting for download
hong kong pack third today and join the
events to win some great prizes
links and info in the description below
and with that said
let's get on with the video the fate
series is one of the most expansive
franchises in all
of anime in between all the games anime
manga light novel visual novels
spin-offs
it's probably one of the most daunting
franchises for any newbie to try to get
into a little while ago i made a joke
skit called
trying to understand the fate franchise
based around how confusing the entire
thing looked
for an outsider looking in and satire
aside
it was based on many real-life
conversations i've actually had with
fate fans trying to explain the
franchise to newcomers and every time
that happens i always hear
do you want the long version or do you
want the shore version because
everyone asks for the short version but
even the short version for an outsider
can seem like a convoluted mess of
information so what you were going to
give me the short version
this is the short version but ever since
i made that video because no one ever
actually asked for it i've always
wondered to myself
what is the long version
the faint franchise fascinates me
originally created by kinokunasu what
started as just a single iroque visual
novel was turned into a multi-billion
dollar franchise with more media than
any sane person can wrap their head
around i mean just
look at all this [ __ ] can you see how
many there is
there's at least five so it can be easy
to forget
how and why people became fans in the
first place that many newcomers may even
forget to ask
what is fate even about
don't worry i got you the basic premise
revolves around a bunch of mages who can
summon heroic spirits from earth's real
history or legends to do battle over the
holy grail a mythical wish granting
device
in what is called the holy grail war
basically it's a bunch of major spending
all their v
bucks organized the ultimate fortnight
apex legend
[ __ ] minecraft hunger games battle
royale between all your favorite people
from history and legend
to create the ultimate showdown of
ultimate destiny
god i hope my audience isn't too young
to understand that reference and the
holy grail war it's just basically nasty
going
[Music]
wow
let's just cut the video there that's
all you need to know about fate however
the back random law of the entire phage
universe is unimaginably deeper than
that
so much so that every single spin-off
anime manga
novel every single piece of fate media
takes place in the coherent universe
fitting somewhere on a grand timeline
which is also shared with nasu's other
works creating this grand
universe known only as the nasu verse so
you know what i thought would be a good
idea
what if i tried explaining the entire
fate timeline keyword being thought
implying it was me in the past tense it
was a [ __ ] idea
explaining all the fake lore and
timeline in detail would take
hours and hours i mean just look at some
of these wiki pages this isn't a wiki
page it's a [ __ ] light novel
sable that time some slag upon threw a
sword at me and i accidentally became
the [ __ ] king of england so this is
more like the long
short version or is it the short long
version or
is it the medium version it's an excuse
to justify all the countless hours i've
put into this hell hole obviously there
is going to be spoilers but
i'm going to try and keep it focused on
the law and universe and where every
series fits in the timeline
rather than what actually happens in any
individual series
so hopefully it won't spoil your
experience too much if you decide to
walk into hell with us so with that said
let's start explaining all of fate
it's not too late now gone all you have
to do is just turn the camera off and
delete the file and no one will ever
have to know
you see that gigguk that was gigguk
three months ago
i've been putting off filming this for
three [ __ ] months just just
kill me now ah three [ __ ] months this
is my dissertation all over again hello
and welcome to my ted talk
to be introducing the fake timeline i'm
going to be cosplaying the most powerful
servant in the history of the fate
timeline steve handjobs but before we
get to the fate timeline there are a few
core concepts we need to bang out first
so
everything makes sense firstly is akasha
see fate exists in this grand world of
magic
and mages where you can summon heroic
beings from the past present and future
and all this derives from akasha what is
akasha siokasha is this metaphysical
place that exists outside of time and
dimensions that is the source of all
events and all the souls in all
timelines and i like using big words to
make me sound smart
basically everything that's ever
happened and everyone you know
you can thank akasha for it 2020 as a
whole
thanks akasha the chat himself chug jugs
fortnite remix
thanks akasha the one time in class you
thought you had a silent fart but you
ripped out that one and everyone heard
it and stared at you and your brain
still reminds you about it every time
you go about to sleep
[ __ ] you akasha so instead of wibbly
wobbly tiny whiny stuff
this is more like wibbly wobbly tiny
whimey goopy galaxy
diddly dimension rickety reality
stuff where every timeline and every
reality exists at the same time meaning
there are no spin-offs every fate is
cannon life is a line yes that smutty
dojin of minamoto going either
on the order order is cannon in some
timeline you can't prove me otherwise
are you with me good this is important
because the end's goal
of every mage in the fake universe is to
find a way to reach
the root of akasha but giga why do all
mages want to find the root of akasha
well i'm glad you asked probably
confused viewer
i really hope you're not confused right
now this is just the beginning well this
would be a good time to talk about the
magic system that exists in the nasi
verse because
as we all know in this universe mages
exist and use
mage craft aka magic right
wrong incorrect
erroneous mistaken
i can't think of any more words off the
top of my head what are you an idiot
why would anyone assume that magic and
magecraft are the same thing
look at this guy typical man that can't
tell the difference between
magic and mage craft no no no no you got
mage craft the weak source imitation
butter oh i can't believe it's not magic
and then you got the chad true magic
this is the top tier
gourmet [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] real mages
want to use
the kind of [ __ ] gordon rounds he has to
taste up and goes
finally magic but this premium [ __ ] can
only be achieved by mages who view
akasha and once someone gets that magic
that path to akasha is cut off and then
the magic can only be used by the direct
descendants of that original mage
basically no one has real magic and
they're trying to get to the root of
akasha so they can stop using the
pleasant dollar store magecraft [ __ ] oh
man what if the third magic was just
the power to create fake porn but what's
stopping all mages from getting to this
mythical place called akasha well you
have this thing
called the counter force this is kind of
like a safety mechanism that stops the
world from going extinct because the
earth is actually alive and has a will
and don't worry about that right now
and the counter force itself is made up
of two parts the collective unconscious
will love humanity itself to survive
a liar and the will of the planet itself
gaia online why is this important
because the counterforce has powerful
defense mechanisms like being able to
summon heroic spirits from earth's
history
in order to defend itself which we call
servants
sound familiar i understood that
reference so it'll intervene anyone
trying to get to akasha aka the goopy
galaxy timey winery place and majors
have to find a way around it
are you with me are you with me good if
you're already confused may i introduce
to you the phrase
everyone in the fate fandom holds in the
highest esteem as the holiest words in
our gospel
don't worry about it why is the cast of
fate state night sharing a nice
wholesome meal instead of trying to
brutally murder each other
don't worry about it how do reality
bubbles work
don't worry about it what is the move
don't worry about it no please please
don't worry about it please don't ask me
what the moon is i'm not gonna [ __ ]
talk about the moon
to recap you have a car show the time
you why me goofy galaxy rickety reality
place that every mage is trying to get
to
so they can use the top tier gourmet
true magic
but the only thing stopping them is the
counterforce which they have to try and
find a way around
did you get all that this is all the
background information you need to know
before we start the timeline jesus
christ we haven't even started the
timeline yet
you know originally i wanted to
visualize the timeline physically by
having things stuck against the walls
strung together with a string or
something like that like you see in that
always sunny meme
but then i soon realized i don't have a
wall big enough
so that's why i'm using the green screen
definitely not because i want to rip off
nakey jakey
now starting right at the beginning
before any majors before any servants
before any holy grail wars
you have the age of god so yeah
apparently right at the beginning of
fate law there was this period of time
where
gods roamed the earth with man mythical
creatures existed
and i [ __ ] you not physics apparently
just
wasn't a thing yeah apparently this
thing called mystery
governed the law of the world which i
don't know what that's supposed to mean
don't worry about it like i just
imagined my head some ancient humans
trying to let go of an apple and physics
tries to drop it and mystery is like no
no
no no we do not do that here and then
the apple just flies off the [ __ ]
narnia but everything changed when the
sephora nation attacked
or joseph this next time period is
called
deterioration this titan called zephyr
invaded and destroyed most of the world
and was only beaten back
by this mighty sword called excalibur
after the attack the gods weaken a bit
mystery starts to wane and physics is
like yo ism
is is anyone gonna drop that apple which
takes us to
separation so the gods are a little
pissed that they can't go down to earth
anymore because they're so weak
so they make gilgamesh who's two-thirds
god
because gods don't give a [ __ ] about
maths apparently with the intention of
making him the keystone to connect the
gods and the humans now for anyone not
familiar with the fate verse
how can i explain gilgamesh you know
that one meme
is this some peasant joke i'm too poor
to understand well
imagine if that meme was reincarnated as
a person
that's gilgamesh so yeah he decides to
rebel and the gods were like no
this guy this guy doesn't want to take
orders from us no come on come on
you're joshing us right now this is a
prank come on where's the hidden cameras
i'm on mtv punks aren't i and so with
that the gods cannot interfere with
humans anymore
and thus begins the age of man from the
year 0
a.d the human population explodes magic
and magecraft is replaced with science
and most importantly physics exists now
guys
yeah i was meant to buy a party popper
but i completely forgot to
alan can you uh can you edit a party
popper in this video please
thank you that's right screw your
mystery i have e equals mt squared
okay remember right at the beginning of
this video when i said the fate
franchise was about this thing called
the holy grail
well we can finally start talking about
the holy grail see the grail is touted
as this omnipotent
magical wish granting device and that's
only partially true see around the 1800s
these epic magic
gamer girls called the einsburns family
figured out a way to the root of akasha
that place that gives you true epic game
and magic
by using the holy grail to summon seven
heroic spirits and then sacrifice them
and using that manner to summon an even
greater grail called
the greater grail which has access to
the root of akasha but of course all the
various magic gamer girls and boys
couldn't agree on who would actually get
access to this magic
so they decided to have a meeting to
decide
one could even say that it was a magic
the gathering or in fate we just call
this the holy grail war which finally
leads us to the timelines to all the war
so far oh i can't believe i flunked
world history and i'm about to recite
the entire history of some
fictional war that happened okay so you
got like the first holy grail war which
happened around the 1800s
this is when the three main mage
families the einsburns
the toe suckers and the mottos couldn't
agree on who could get access to the
grave so they were like guys
we've got a bunch of servants lying
about 20 minutes tournament
tournament this was hardly what you'd
call a natural war though and more like
a 3 a.m role at the local magepad which
ended because
everyone got bored and time ran out then
came the second holy grail war in the
1860s with the same parties involved but
this time
everyone went a bit [ __ ] mental
because everyone died nobody won
and future generations were like wait a
minute do we need
rules what the [ __ ] is a geneva
convention
then came the third holy grail war in
the 1930s where the church gets involved
because they're just like
um are you using the term holy
grail god are we allowed to copy strike
that
and everyone's happy with that because
they can enforce the rules so the church
is like alright gamers i want a fair
fight
no going for the eyes no kicking below
the belt and for god's sakes
no summoning any illegal servants so
then the irons burn summon an illegal
servant
and so they get this totally new servant
called angra mayu aka the angry mango
who's meant to be this super badass
ultra op new serpent that also wins on
the ward except lol jk is actually super
weak
and dies and is literally so angry he
gives the grill food poisoning then
we've got the fourth holy grail war
which is basically just the events of
fate zero i'm not gonna spoil what
happens in it
and finally we have the grand sugar
daddy the birth
everything we're talking about the fifth
holy grail war aka the events of fate
stay night
following shiro fighting in it using the
power of friendship and [ __ ] i mean
mana transfer and this cg dragon still
haunts my nightmares what's important
here is that this war has at least
three different timelines because the
original fate stay night
was a visual novel with three different
routes got the fate root
unlimited blade words and heavens feel
or to put it more simply
you got the saber root the best girl
root and the sakura roots with extra
[ __ ] i mean mana transfer
but it doesn't stop there because next
we've got fate hollow anorexia which is
kind of like a sequel to fate stay night
because it takes place six months after
the events that happened in there
so you may be wondering which one of the
three routes it follows
and the answer is yes so one of the main
girls from fate stay night rain is doing
some magic experiments and
she does a little bit of a loopsie and
um completely [ __ ] up the space-time
continuum
merging all parallel universes together
and i know what you're thinking
this doesn't sound like a little you've
seen this sounds a bit more like a
big oopsie but it's all good because she
looks great in thigh highs so we're
following this mage posset who was dead
off screen in the original face they
unite and she is now alive along with
angra mayu aka the angry mango and
they're stuck in a groundhog daytime
time loop living the same four days over
and over and she has to find a way to
escape without fading from existence
because she was originally dead and i
guess people die if they don't exist
since most of this takes place in the
time loop this is basically just
fate re-zero edition so you can
essentially just call it
fate zero wait and you know what that's
basically everything for the flagship
phase series
we did it guys that was pretty simple
right guys
what are we missing
of course we are going to have to fill
this timeline in with all the other fake
media out there so
let's do the time warp again
oh my alan god cut that all right so
let's start with fate apocrypha so the
fate of poker for timeline is exactly
identical to the original timeline
except when we get to the third holy
grail war where the timeline was like
you know what nazis
because of course it's the [ __ ] nazis
so the nazis joined the third holy grail
war and instead of there being a winner
the nazis steal the greater grail system
and so after that a transylvanian nazi
mage guy steals it from the nazis again
and then i guess the nazis go on to lose
world war ii as usual fast forward to
the future and somehow the entire world
finds out about the greater grail system
and everyone and their dog tries to make
a cheap imitation of it
and so because of this the transylvanian
nazi sorcery guy
vows to make the holy grail war great
again
and so he makes the great
holy grail war i [ __ ] you know this is
what it's called
and so now instead of seven servants you
have 14 servants separated into two
teams
red and black that's right it's a team
deathmatch
and so we get a season of red versus
black mordred is hot and a stealth will
make straight guys question their
sexuality and gay guys question their
sexuality and gay girls question their
sexuality
and me question my life choices for
spending 400 for a dick
that concludes the events of hitler's
day night next on the menu we have
today's menu for emir family
did you see what i did there this is i
think just another ultimate ending to
the fifth holy grail wall where i guess
nobody dies and they all just sit around
cooking and playing volleyball and being
happy and this is canon okay
they never explain where this takes
place on the timeline but i don't care
they're all happy akasha made it it's
canon
like in my mind this is the reality when
someone just tried playing the fake
visual novel but got bored five minutes
after reading words and then just
left and never came back and then all
these characters are just sitting around
having a gay old time waiting for the
holy grail war to start
this is what happened this is the
reality where sea dog va tried to play
fate
all right so i'm just gonna make a fate
stay night bubble and then i'm gonna put
fake tiger coliseum and fake unlimited
codes in this bubble
because they're just fighting games and
they're already beating the [ __ ] out of
each other in the series anyway
so i guess these are just the filler
episodes we never got to see
then we've got fate school life which is
kind of like a slice of life spin-off in
the fate stay night universe that also
has anorexia characters in it so i guess
it goes
here can you tell how i'm sure i am
right now
lord elman lloyd's case files this is
basically just csi magic that takes
place
after phase zero but before face day
night starring fate zero's waiver
except wave has gone from daddy stuff on
me to
oh death on me daddy
alright now we get into the manly [ __ ]
fate
dj khaled line of prisoner ilya is a
spin-off where ilya becomes a magical
girl
and instead of summoning servants the
magical girls can use these magical
cards to channel the power of the
servant
and also there's a magical talk he wants
don't worry about it before i properly
got into the fake franchise i thought
that this was just an unrelated spin-off
that had nothing to do with the main
universe but
no not only does this directly diverge
from the main timeline
but it has two separate universes within
its own universe it's a [ __ ] ilia
multiverse
and the beginning of the ilia multiverse
doesn't even have ilia in it oh god i
love you so much faber you just don't
make things
easy do you all right i'm going to try
and do my best so stick with me here the
first universe is the one
detailed in the movie oath under snow
following this girl called miyu which is
why we call this the me
verse because her name is miyu and she's
the child of god don't worry about it
she's taken in by shiro and then they
have another holy grail war but not the
usual heligram war but the iron's worth
holy grail war
can you guess why it's called the
ironsworth holy grail war
because it was made by the irons shiro
then sends miu to an alternate universe
which we call the ilia verse which is
all sunshine and rainbows
where the fourth holy grail war didn't
happen in kiritsugu's father of the year
you've got cute girls doing cute things
cute girls doing magical things
and cute girls doing each other this is
the universe where season one and two of
prisma ilia happens but then you have
season three
which jumps back into the miuiverse and
if you think that complicates the
timeline how about this little knowledge
of nugget
so in the original face day night ilya
is 18. she's 18.
she's older than shiro but in the ilia
verse she's the same age as when the
timelines diverge
which theoretically should make her the
same age as she was in fate stay night
but she's not and the series makes it
very clear
that she is under 18. so which is it
fate
which is it i need to know you know i
would say don't worry about it
but i'm pretty sure the fbi are going to
do that for me all right moving the [ __ ]
on from this mess of a legal situation
you're fate also known as the fate x-ray
universe
this leads up from the third holy grail
war in the angry mango timeline where
all the world's mana dries up because
some kind of
event so in the 2030s all the majors
turned into hackers and they tried to
hack the moon because the moon has a
supercomputer on it that was placed
there by aliens that they found and so
inside this supercomputer moon there
exists this entire digital world
and so the supercomputer moon is hosting
a virtual reality holy grail war
because it's actually alive
i don't realize how ridiculous this
sounds until i read it out loud don't
worry about it so yeah it turns out the
moon knows [ __ ] and you can hack the
moon and it also
has rin sakura and kiro from the
original face day night but not the
original
rin sucker and kiro from the original
face day night
what are you stupid they're just
characters who look
sound and dress exactly the same but
they're different
are you worrying about it because i'm
not sure you got the fake extra games
the fate extra triple c
games and then you got the anime fate
extra last
encore in its own separate timeline that
takes place in the year three
thousand and rin's great great great
granddaughter
just [ __ ] rin fate grand order oh
god you're not gonna make me break down
fake grand order all right
now we're truly in hell so fago is a
mobile gadget game along some anime
adaptations where the first holy grail
war never happens
the world is [ __ ] for some reason and
you have got to travel back in time to
various points in history
to fix the [ __ ] timeline and every
different timeline you fix
is called singularities basically
imagine fade back to the feature except
there are like seven sequels all with
different diverging timelines
and you're not trying to [ __ ] your mum
you're just trying to [ __ ] with the
servants
all right so for simplicity's sake i
think it would just be easier if i just
draw out the fake go timeline
and then here in its own corner it's
just fake prototype which is
kinokunasu's original concept for fate
where king arthur arthur's actually a
guy
get get out of here with your damn
historical inaccuracies
so essentially this is just a
non-existent project because the only
thing that exists
is a 12-minute trailer that was made
purely for fan service
which is even more bizarre when you
consider
fate prototype fragments of sky silver
which is the prequel to fate prototype
they made a prequel a full light novel
prequel
to a 12 minute commercial like did i
really think fake fans are that hungry
for content
our type moon just sitting there being
like all right fake fans
open wide oh content ah
give me anything and then this prequel
to a project that basically doesn't even
exist as a side story called fate
labyrinth
a side story this is why tsukihime fans
are on suicide watch
you can tell that line was written
months ago because um
yeah where the [ __ ] did this come from
and all this would be a completely
ultimate universe with
no connection to the original universe
but i [ __ ] you not
one of the characters has a dream that
connects this universe
to the face they unite universe
yup it's literally cannon my dream
all right i think we're getting close to
the end next is fate strange fake
this is a light novel series that takes
place after the fifa holy grail war in
america where they do their own holy
grail war with hookers and blackjack
written by the same guy who did buccano
as a recording we don't know if this
follows on from the main flagship
timeline or as part of an alternate
universe but what we do know
is that there's a servant called watcher
and it's literally just a [ __ ] whale
in the sky
i'm sorry i must have missed the legend
where a [ __ ] flying whale saves earth
does free willy count as a legendary
hero of history now
that's fate type redline it's tokyo in
the 1940s nazis are at it again but this
time so are the japanese military it's
the third grill world with seemingly no
other connections to any of the grails
and it's the manga drawn by the demon
slayer mangaka we got fate requiem not a
lot about this is known right now
because it's not been officially
translated but what we do know
is that it's set in the future after
some kind of holy grail war and
somehow everyone has their own holy
grail and also there's this new servant
called voyager who i guess
is the voyager space probe except i have
no [ __ ] clue how a space pro becomes
a servant
let alone a blonde show to boy let alone
a blonde show to boy space probe servant
and don't tell me to worry about
it because i'm not can you see how much
i'm not worrying about it
i am not worrying about it
but seriously how the [ __ ] and finally
in a bubble with
its own bubble within its own [ __ ]
dimension is carnival
phantasm where all the fake characters
and other characters from nasu's other
works
are just hanging out i guess doesn't
make any sense i have no idea where this
fits on the timeline
i think this is just the bubble reality
where kasha got [ __ ] drunk
and that's it that
is the long version kinda
oh but gigan what about the rest of the
nazi verse are you gonna do that as well
how about no originally this was meant
to be a grand video where it talks about
all the funny and ridiculous things i
found out about fate law as a whole
but when i started it i kind of realized
i'm gonna need 20 minutes just to
explain the [ __ ] timeline
so you know what this may just be the
first part in a multi-series lecture
from hell
because the worst thing about fate is
that after going through all the
timelines after connecting all the law
after spending far
too many hours consuming fate media and
reading pages upon pages of wiki
articles
it kind of makes sense oh
god this chart actually makes sense to
me the entire timeline is actually the
simplest part of fate lore
fate is just an all-encompassing hole
that just gets darker and gloomier the
deeper you go
down people wonder what's at the bottom
of the abyss
in maiden abyss it's just the [ __ ]
entrance to the fate hole you want the
real short version fake newcomers
you watch either of these two and then
watch this
and then watch whatever the [ __ ] you
want or you know what
[ __ ] all this start with the spin-off
series start with lesbian lolly's
kissing start with fate masterchef [ __ ]
start with the dejinches for all i care
just ignore all the shitstorm going on
in the comments section right now
the reality is it doesn't really matter
where you start as long as it looks
interesting to you
then go for it the problem is there's so
many people who are obsessed with
optimizing the perfect
read and watch order that they forget
that if you enjoy the experience and it
gets you into fate
then who the [ __ ] cares what order you
watch it in because look
memes aside the fate lore may be a
convoluted mess to unravel
but it is an awesome franchise it's a
series that can have amazing fights with
balls to the walls action and magical
moments that cut deep into your heart
and then thomas edison shows up as a
lion because if you've reached the end
of this video knowing nothing about fate
and
this is the video that's convinced you
to give it a try
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you this
this got you interested in fate oh god
why didn't you just listen to me the
first time and go over the short version
you know what [ __ ] this i'm done i'm
done
i'm not doing fate anymore i'm literally
gonna go crazy
you know what i lied this isn't even the
long version
hey guys i really hope you enjoyed that
video thank you again to hong kong
impact for sponsoring me today
and also thank you very much to ivito
the walter payne patchett elephant
basil and everyone else my patreon for
supporting me for this month but
especially garrett and lucas for being
my fate gurus and
guiding me through this hell that is the
fate hole honestly couldn't have done it
without you too so thank you very much
for being my gurus and thank you very
much for
helping me do the research for all the
information i put in here and also
thank you very much to everyone on my
patreon discord server for fact checking
this video
before it went live basically what i'm
trying to say is if anything in this
video is inaccurate or wrong
you can blame an entire discord server
for it
something's still probably wrong though
and if you want to join the monthly
calls where literally someone mentions
fate every [ __ ] month which is how
this video got started in the first
place
check out my patreon or don't please
you don't need any more people talking
about fake but yeah this video has been
in production for
way too long mostly because the
groundwork was done
last year and i really hope you enjoy
the style of this video because it took
a lot of work and i don't know if you
could tell but i had a really
really fun time filming this video me
and my editor
have been putting off working on this
video for so long because we knew how
much work it would take but yeah as i
said earlier this probably
won't be the only fate video i put out
because
we've done way more research than what
i've put into this video
so i hope you're excited for the next
one because both me and my editor
are really looking forward to working on
another video like this
right alan that alan
such a joker anyway that's it from me no
further updates i've been
gigak and i hope you enjoy the hell
we're about to walk into
because i'm not